Німецьку армію - Бундесвер
заснували через 10 років після завершення
Другої світової війни
У Констутиції закріплений контроль
парламенту над армією
Лише за згоди німецького парламенту
солдати Бундесверу
можуть бути розміщені за кордоном
Щороку Бундестаг дискутує щодо ефективності закордонної місії
і приймає рішення про продовження
мандату ще на рік
Федеральний уряд повинен також
отримати згоду Бундестагу
на використання збройних сил у разі нападу на ФРН
Німецький парламент також визначає
розмір оборонного бюджету ФРН
Постійний комітет з питань оборони Бундестагу здійснює
парламентський контроль
за міністерством оборони
Оборонний комітет серед іншого наділений функціями слідчої комісії
яка має право опитувати свідків,
вимагати документи
чи відвідувати Бундесвер,
зокрема у закордонних місіях
Комітет відіграє важливу роль у прийнятті оборонного бюджету ФРН
З ним узгоджують і закупівлі для Бундесверу
Ще один парламентський орган контролю
уповноважений Бундестагу з військових питань
Він приймає скарги від солдатів,
розглядає конфліктні ситуації
Уповноважений щороку готує детальний звіт
про стан справ у Бундесвері
Бундесвером керує міністр оборони
в 2013 році ним уперше стала жінка,
Урсула фон дер Ляєн
Вона - головнокомандувачка у мирний час
У разі необхідності оборонних дій командування переходить до канцлера Німеччини
Це можна перекласти як
"Внутрішній кодекс поведінки"
Згідно з ним військовослужбовець
це громадянин у формі, який особливо зацікавлений
у дотриманні цінностей та норм Основного закону
Кодекс - підстава для відповідальних дій
кожного солдата
Воїн повинен обмірковувати
і аналізувати ситуацію
а не сліпо підпорядковуватися
Солдати мають право не виконувати накази
якщо вони злочинні або не мають службової цілі
Також солдати можуть скаржитися на своє керівництво
до вищого командування
або уповноваженого Бундестагу
з військових питань
Права, закріплені в Основному законі
однаково застосовуються до цивільних та солдатів